[Music]
we have the news photos that everybody
is talking about Jamie Foxx and Katie
Holmes holding hands on the beach you
know Nancy after years of speculation
rumors in innuendo can we finally put
Hollywood's worst kept secret to rest
these two are way more than just friends
Jamie Foxx and Katie Holmes stepped out
in public as a couple for the first time
on Labor Day they walk hand-in-hand on a
Malibu beach played in the surf snap
photos and according to one eyewitness
quote they look like a pair of young
kids in love so how long has this secret
romance been going on while the rumors
first surfaced in 2013 when Katie and
Jamie were seen dancing together at a
benefit in the Hamptons here's what
Jamie told Nancy about the rumours in
2015 so clarify you're not dating Katie
you know the tabloids have you very much
in love yeah yeah all the time but but
but what I've learned about society
today is that they're so thirsty
especially in tabloid world and in
social media world speaking of social
media in April of this year a blogger
snapped this photo of Katie and Jamie
dining together in New York City I like
to stay quiet you know with anyone that
I'm dating that I'm really really big
you manage to get yeah it's like I just
I feel like this there's somebody that
you're dating the worst thing you could
do is let that touch you but there could
be at least one other reason they've
kept the relationship under wraps a
source tells us that / Katie's divorce
settlement with Tom Cruise
the actress agreed not to go public with
the new romance for at least five years
their divorce was finalized five years
ago in August we reached out today to
reps for Katie and Jamie and did not
hear back by our deadline just hours
after the images surfaced Tom was
snapped landing in London by helicopter
the actor was all smiles and had a big
thumbs up
[Music]